so this is an astronaut with a ribbon
around him floating through the Galaxy
what would you call this guy a mariner 1
th000 again just like the one before cuz
it seems like it's pretty huge
1,500
2400 that makes sense it's one almost
$1,200 yeah I could see that dude this
is very cool 1,200
huh like a kitsun nin tailed fox with a
chick this is huge it's like a full
sleeve one from shoulder to wrist
fantasy like a Japanese type of work I
like it man that's cool 1,500 for
something like this since it's like so
huge because of the size I will say
$4,000 I'm going to go a limb here I
guess
1,200
700 W that's a good deal oh that's a
great deal they must have been pretty
good homies 700 will get you something
like a little bit bigger than your hand
like a hand size honestly